qui surmonte un ronald koeman et c'est
un tour d'horizon d'une humanité blessés
partout dans le monde que le souverain
pontife a décrit dans son traditionnel
discours urbi et orbi à la ville de rome
et au monde devant quelques cinquante
cinq mille fidèles réunis sur la place
saint pierre le pape françois appelé à
assouplir notre coeur souvent endurci et
égoïste afin de donner le sourire aux
enfants du monde entier
si confortable amato popolo siriano
encore à nombre de la fidh et les
hostilités le nord-ouest du pays est
déchiré depuis deux semaines encore par
de violents combats au sol entre
djihadistes rebelles
françois appelé les gouvernants et la
communauté internationale à trouver des
solutions qui garantissent la sécurité
et la coexistence pacifique des peuples
de la région notamment le yémen et
l'irak
si s obstine yoplait hip hop relie
vanesse et quelques postes à auchy dans
la toile et crise et il a apporté son
soutien au peuple libanais secoué par un
mouvement de contestation politique sans
précédent
il espère que le pays redécouvre sa
vocation de messages et liberty et
linzhou steel temarii façon matter in
chimay tv le pacte françois vivement
critiquée par les politiciens populistes
s'est porté à la défense des migrants
qui subissent l'esclavagé la torture et
la détention dans des camps piccolo
bamenda mais par tout un continent
américain
françois qui vient de fêter ses 83 ans a
regretté l'agitation sociale et
politique que traverse les pays du
continent américain
il estime que le peuple vénézuélien doit
obtenir l'aide dont il a besoin
en afrique il a dénoncé la persécution
des chrétiens par des groupes
extrémistes au burkina faso au mali au
niger et au nigeria
[Musique]
lors de son homélie de noël mardi soir
dans une basilique saint-pierre comble
le pape avait prôné l'amour
inconditionnel et gratuit opposé à la
logique marchande qui prévaut l'image de
l'église a été encore entaché par de
vastes scandales d'abus sexuels commis
par le clergé
ici à smic ryan radio canada montréal